Iran explained like your five.
Step 1.
Iran, once called Persia, has one of the oldest continuous civilizations on Earth, over 2,500
years old.
In the 6th century BC, Cyrus the Great built the foundation of an empire that soon stretched
from Egypt to India, the largest the world had yet seen, known for governing conquered
peoples with unusual tolerance for the time.
That empire fell to Alexander the Great, but Persia kept rebuilding itself under new dynasties
for 2,000 years, never disappearing the way most ancient empires did.
This is the first thing you need to understand about Iran.
It has been conquered many times and has never stopped being Persia underneath.
Step 2.
By the 20th century, Iran was ruled by a monarchy, the Shah.
In 1951, Iran's elected Prime Minister, Mohammad Mossadegh, nationalized the country's oil
industry.
In 1953, a coup organized by the American CIA and British intelligence removed him and
returned full power to the Shah, who ruled for 26 more years with Western backing.
In 1979, mass protests against the Shah's rule turned into a full revolution.
He fled the country and an exiled religious leader, Ayatollah Khomeini, returned to found
the Islamic Republic of Iran.
Step 3.
A year later, Iraq invaded Iran, starting a war that lasted eight years and killed an
estimated one million people on both sides combined, one of the deadliest wars of the
20th century that most of the world barely remembers.
Since then, Iran has clashed with the West over its nuclear program and has periodically
erupted in mass protests at home, most recently the 2022 Woman Life Freedom Movement following
the death of Masa Amini in police custody.
Step 4.
Today, Iran is a theocracy that still holds elections for some offices, still faces street
protests at answers with force, and still sits at the center of tensions across the
Middle East.
Iran is the empire that has fallen and rebuilt itself more times than almost any other country
on Earth and is still doing it today.
And that's just one story inside Paladin.
It's like Duolingo, but for history.
Download it now and become the most intelligent person in the room.